[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados las armas de fuego
se han convertido en un problema
endémico en eeuu en lo que va de año se
han producido más de 200 tiroteos en el
país y en 2021 se registraron
693 según datos del gun violence arkaitz
cada vez que se produce un acto de
violencia armada a gran escala se reabre
el eterno debate en torno a un mayor
control de armas pero los avances son
pocos por no decir nulos porque están
las armas tan arraigadas en la cultura
estadounidense porque el lobby
armamentístico es tan poderoso y qué
impacto tienen la política y por qué
fracasan los esfuerzos para cambiar esta
situación iniciemos con un panorama de
la problemática sólo en 2020 más de 45
mil estadounidenses murieron a causa de
un arma de fuego
24 mil 300 fueron suicidios y 19 mil 400
homicidios según small arms orbe en 2018
había unos
390 millones de armas en manos de
civiles en el país
unas 120 como cinco armas de fuego por
cada 100 habitantes es decir en eeuu hay
más armas circulando que personas la
facilidad para acceder a ellas tiene
origen en gran parte en la constitución
del país y en su famosa segunda enmienda
que ve como un derecho intrínseco de
cualquier ciudadano estadounidense la
adquisición y el porte de armas para
adquirir un arma en eeuu la principal
condición es haber cumplido 18 años y
los negocios que las venden deben
realizar un chequeo automático de
antecedentes del comprador un proceso
rápido que apenas toma unos segundos
este sistema tiene sus fallas pues las
personas también pueden acceder a
armamento a través de vendedores
privados donde comprobará antecedentes
no es un requisito el problema radica
también en el tipo de armamento al cual
es posible acceder en 1999 la masacre en
columbine dejó 15 muertos en 2012 otra
en sandy hook 28 muertos en 2016 en
orlando 49 muertos en 2017 en las vegas'
58 muertos
y más recientemente la de igual de texas
dejó 19 niños y dos adultos fallecidos
el rifle ar-15 ha sido el protagonista
en todas estas masacres un fusil
semiautomático
diseñado originalmente para el ejército
estadounidense pero que tiene una
versión para uso civil con el horror que
deja cada tiroteo llegan los deseos de
cambio y mayor regulación e incluso las
encuestas más recientes reflejan un
apoyo del 75% entre la población del
país por regular las armas pero una y
otra vez las situaciones se estanca a
nivel político es aquí donde el lobby de
las armas juega un papel determinante el
más importante es el de la asociación
nacional del rifle en área que se opone
a la regularización del porte de armas y
promete enfrentar el lo que considera
actividades que atentan contra la
segunda enmienda de la nba defiende que
entre más armas haya en la población más
seguridad habrá porque los ciudadanos
buenos podrán defenderse de lo que
llaman los ciudadanos malos este lo vio
hasta anual enormes sumas de dinero para
influir en los miembros del congreso de
eeuu
financiando campañas de senadores e
incluso aspirantes a la presidencia
la de nerea dice tener 5 millones de
miembros activos una cifra discutible
pero con una innegable influencia sobre
un amplio bloque de votantes y es que
oponerse a la nba esa vez es sinónimo de
sepultar una carrera política en esta
asociación se habla de falta de
seguridad abogan por ejemplo por armar a
los maestros en las escuelas e insisten
en que son los problemas de salud mental
los que están en el origen del conflicto
e impulsan la narrativa de que el
gobierno buscará quitarle las armas a la
gente logrando que después de cada
tiroteo la venta de armas se dispare en
el país podrá el congreso revertir esta
situación el partido demócrata del
presidente de joe biden ha propuesto
varias medidas para regular las armas
como el aumento de la edad de compra de
18 a 21 años o prohibir las armas de
asalto y los cargadores de alta
capacidad pero también a ser más
estrictos los controles de antecedentes
de quienes quieren comprar y poder
demandar a los fabricantes por los
crímenes que se cometan con las armas
que producen pero mientras gran parte de
los demócratas en el congreso
pollán más restricciones el partido
republicano
fiel aliado de la asociación nacional
del rifle se opone firmemente en
coherencia con la mayoría de sus
votantes actualmente el partido
demócrata tiene la mayoría en la cámara
de representantes pero cuenta con una
mayoría demasiado estrecha en el senado
donde necesitaría al menos 60 votos para
lograr cambios significativos esta
situación podría empeorar tras las
elecciones de medio término de noviembre
donde los demócratas se arriesgan a
perder sus mayorías así las cosas está
en manos de la sociedad estadounidense
seguir presionando en las calles y en
las urnas para lograr cambiar esta
cultura de las armas tan arraigada en el
país si les sirvió el vídeo para
entender por qué la violencia armada
están presentes en eeuu y por qué es tan
difícil regularlo los esperamos en otro
episodio de en cinco minutos en france
24 y france24 puntocom